when we looked at a homomorphic
encryption as a target for training as
we were doing in parasail we noticed
that there's actually a lot of other
lower hanging fruit that's we can do for
homomorphic encryption and instead of
training we started looking at inference
so how do you even evaluate a neural
network model on top of homomorphic
encryption which is a thing you need to
be able to do before you can actually do
training so what Chet is doing is it is
building a compiler for homomorphic
encryption that automates many of these
concerns that we would otherwise have to
deal with by hand you're listening to
the Microsoft Research podcast a show
that brings you closer to the cutting
edge of technology research and the
scientists behind it I'm your host
Gretchen using
[Music]
as computing moves to the cloud there's
an increasing need for privacy and AI in
an ideal world users would have the
ability to compute unencrypted data
without sacrificing performance enter
dr. Ali Sarek IV a postdoctoral
researcher in the rhys group at MSR he
along with a stellar group of
cross-disciplinary colleagues are
bridging the gap with Chet
a compiler and runtime for homomorphic
evaluation of tensor programs that keeps
data private while making the
complexities of homomorphic encryption
schemes opaque to users on today's
podcast dr. Sarah Kiva tells us all
about Chet gives us an overview of some
of his other projects including parasail
a novel approach to parallelizing
seemingly sequential applications and
tells us how a series of unconventional
educational experiences shaped his view
of himself and his career as a
researcher that and much more on this
episode of the Microsoft Research
podcast
[Music]
Oly sorry TV welcome to the podcast
thank you so you're a postdoc researcher
in the rise group which is research and
software engineering and you're
interested in and I quote distributing
ml training with semantics preserving
parallelization and advancing private AI
with homomorphic encryption yes and that
was kind of the short story I'm touching
a lot of other things currently also but
yeah if that's the short story we're in
trouble there's a bunch of stuff in
there that we'll unpack as we get into
the specific ways that those are playing
out in the research you're doing but for
now I want to start kind of broad
strokes
tell us what big questions you're asking
what big problems you're trying to solve
what gets you up in the morning so
currently all of my projects are in some
way or the other about performance and
it's not just about looking at a
specific application and figuring out
what's the best way to get this to run
fast it's about finding ways to make
performance accessible to developers and
well there was that privacy-preserving
thing there were looking at making
homomorphic encryption which is a
technique for preserving privacy more
accessible while giving them good
performance when doing that
ok so let's go in a little bit further
on that because I've had several of your
colleagues in Rise on the podcast some
of my favorite people at MSR and they're
working on problems that I care a lot
about in terms of testing and
verification in software which I know
you've had a lot of experience in those
areas as well but your most recent work
has shifted to thing you just mentioned
performance and so I want to know what
you mean by that and what prompted the
pivot from your interest in testing and
verification to performance yeah it is a
very broad term so indeed my background
is in program analysis topics like
symbolic execution software verification
that kind of stuff but it was actually
when I came to Microsoft we worked on
this project for optimizing stream
processing programs and here it's
actually turned out that the same
techniques that were used for analyzing
programs for safety also work for Anna
in programs for applying optimizations
so performance really is about
performance as it's unlocked by powerful
compiler analysis and I think these
kinds of topics are becoming more and
more important as they like computing
landscape gets more and more
heterogeneous we're getting like GPUs
and FPGAs and all kinds of accelerators
and these are hard to use and really we
need to start thinking about these
problems in like a very domain-specific
way or what are they like specific
constraints of what are we compiling to
and it's a thing that you can make more
accessible to a user if you can provide
like good abstractions on top of it
through powerful compiler optimizations
the homomorphic encryption libraries
that we're using are getting
implementations on top of GPUs and FPGAs
on a very high level it looks a lot like
one of these accelerators you get things
like a very constrained programming
model weird performance constraints and
all of these kind of low-level details
that a typical developer has a hard time
grappling with and this is the part
where building a good compiler for it
can help in the same way that's having a
good compiler helps target a GPU if you
don't have to write the lowest level of
code and you can use a bit of a higher
level language so that's kind of what we
want to do for homomorphic encryption
which is kind of just another targets in
the landscape of heterogeneous computing
let's talk about that developer right
now every researcher has a reason
usually in the form of a group of people
for the work they're doing so is that
how you would define your target
audience as developers who are or who do
you think will be the main beneficiaries
of the work you're doing so for the work
we're doing with homomorphic encryption
it is definitely developers in some
specific domain let's say your developer
working for a bank and you want to
increase your privacy by adopting
homomorphic encryption now the thing is
that that developer probably will not be
a cryptographer who's like intimately
familiar with all the details of
homomorphic
encryption but they have all of this
domain-specific knowledge for their own
domain and now we want to enable them to
effectively use tools from homomorphic
encryption in their own domain without
burdening them with all of the crypto
specific details so they can be using
the tools but not being experts in the
science behind the tools yeah and that's
really the aim of any compiler project
like for traditional program it's that
you don't want to force people to use
assembly for their coding and instead
use I don't know c-sharp or something
well let's talk about stream processing
for a minute because I want to land on a
couple of other big projects that you're
involved in that are really cool but
this area of efficient stream processing
is something that you've done a lot of
work in give us an overview of the high
points of what you're doing in this area
what are the technical underpinnings
motivation rationale and what do you
hope the outcomes will be so this is
work that I did during my two
internships at two Microsoft Research
before I became a postdoc so again the
point here is to make performance
accessible without having to kind of go
in and do all the low-level details
yourself so the idea here is that in
this stream processing applications like
let's say you want to parse a log file
and then do some kind of processing on
the things you've parsed out of it and
maybe then do your Curie on top of that
and then encode your data and then write
it back to disk so you have kind of like
many stages when you process inputs into
outputs and a nice way to write these
kinds of programs is to write it as
separate stages it can actually happen
that that's not the best way to do it
for performance one reason is that if
you write it as separate stages you
typically get some kind of buffering in
between the stages sometimes buffering
is good but typically you would get kind
of excessive buffering if you just rises
in these small stages that you compose
again and together and another reason is
that there's lots of opportunities that
you're leaving on the table let's say
you have a very defensive coded
component somewhere later on in your
pipeline that does all of these kind of
checks on the input that it's properly
formatted or whatever but if you now
compose it with some component that is
actually correct and guarantee
to produce purple performance and data
then all of those defensive checks in
this latter components are unnecessary
blanket you should just remove them but
having the developer remove them by hand
is it's a lot of work and then your code
becomes less modular so what we do
instead is that we actually compile all
of these pages separately into this
model of computation called symbolic
transducers which is their suited to
representing stream computations and the
nice thing about these is that we have a
fusion operator defined which allows us
to combine many of these stages as
symbolic transducers in one big symbolic
transducer okay it's basically a form of
inlining kind of with some fancy solver
assisted optimizations happening inside
there and now that we have this one big
transducer that's fused and they do get
big like even though we have a solver
helping there is a blow-up but now at
this point we can actually start
applying these program analysis based
optimizations onto that for example
looking at reach ability of certain
control States and start pruning and
removing stuff from that symbolic
transducer and this allows us to
implement these optimizations that were
not available when these stages were
considered just simply and then when we
generate code for this we can actually
get some very efficient code that does
these inter stage optimizations and
removes buffering and stuff like that
okay who does this matter for the most
so the targets for this kind of thing is
mainly when you are actually dealing
with enough dates at that throughput
matters so typical things might be cloud
kirie applications so we were actually
looking at any internal database system
for integrating this into systems where
you are already burning like lots of
computational power and like running
Curie's against your system and you want
to reduce that to a lower level to save
money it saves time and money
it saves time and money well time is
money yes in computation and other areas
so are there other areas like in the reg
X field that logic comes out yes so that
is actually a direction we took this
project so we actually looked at do
doing regular expression matching using
theory based on the symbolic automata
which is actually important because
regular expressions are not just over
some small alphabets if you're dealing
just with ASCII which is a 128 or
extended ASCII 256 characters you're
fine dealing with it concretely but
symbolic automata allow you to deal with
unicode and larger alphabets which is
the reality in dealing with strings and
doing pattern matching these days and
there's again like all of this ultimate
authority algorithmics available for
optimizing these symbolic automata so
you're able to get some very efficient
regular expression matching routines out
of that and yeah that was actually very
fruitful and work currently beating re2
which is this well-known kind of default
library that people go for high
performance regular expression matching
[Music]
well let's talk about another cool
project you've been a part of called
parasail and your agenda with the
project is and I quote again high
performance ml and encrypted ml what is
parasail and what are the research
challenges and how does it defy
conventional wisdom so it's actually a
very interesting project it's more of a
meta project rather than like just one
specific project so parasail
is a line of research that is concerned
with paralyzing seemingly sequential
computations and the idea behind that is
that if you take a sequential
computation which basically means that
there are some states that evolves
through like a sequence of computational
steps it seems like on the face of it's
hard to paralyze this because you have
this sequential dependency with the
state in getting threaded through each
of the steps of computation but it
actually turns out that you can do
symbolic execution on each of these
stages given a concrete input and by
doing symbolic execution such that you
assume that these starting States is
unknown you can do some pre computation
based on that input and this allows you
to paralyze a lot of the computation
before you actually have to do this
final sequential step of stringing
together these individually executed
steps so why is that important so
there's a lot of data world for example
doing large aggregates at Curie's over
cloud scale databases which have data
splits on two terabytes and terabytes of
data style things and then obviously
machine learning there's huge amounts of
data available for machine learning and
you want to paralyze these kinds of
processes so actually it's this first
thing that I mentioned that I got into
the Paracel project through so we were
actually looking at paralyzing streaming
computations represented as symbolic
transducers which is that other line of
work that I was mentioning but it would
also be useful to paralyze that and now
the idea is to do symbolic execution on
a symbolic transducer to do the
parallelization now if we actually look
at the machine learning part it's very
different the ideas are kind of same on
the very high level but instead of
symbolic execution we are looking at a
second-order optimization method which
has kind of the same flavor but it's not
the same tools and this is why I find
this project especially interesting the
meta-level idea of this kind of
parallelization has been very fruitful
and when we look at specific problems
for example the stream processing stuff
or machine learning stuff you end up
with very different instantiations of
the same idea so we're kind of getting a
lot out of this very simple idea just by
deploying it to different domains and
typically there's a lot of work to apply
it to a new domain but it kind of sets
the framework for the research yeah to
be clear it's a lot of work in general
and then you got new domains to fit it
too right yeah yeah well let's switch
streams again I've had a couple of
guests on the podcast who specialize in
homomorphic encryption which we've
talked about briefly but I'm not going
to assume that all our listeners know
exactly what that is so while it's not
your core expertise it is central to the
project we're gonna talk about next give
us a quick remedial course on
homomorphic encryption and how it works
including the difference between
so-called regular homomorphic encryption
and this flavor that you're working with
called fully homomorphic encryption yeah
so it actually turns out that many
existing encryption schemes are slightly
homomorphic with respect to some
operations so let's take as an example
RSA which is a commonly used encryption
scheme so it has the property that if
you encrypt an integer a using RSA and
you get a ciphertext for a and then you
encrypt an integer B also with RSA so
now you have two cipher texts so you can
multiply these two ciphertext together
so RSA has a special homomorphic
property that if you multiply two
ciphertext together you get a new
ciphertext that is the encryption of
what the multiplication of a and B would
have been so what in effects you have
done is that you have done computation
on encrypted values and the magical
thing is that you didn't need the secret
key to be able to do this compute so
homomorphic encryption is a form of
encryption that allows you to do
computation on encrypted data without
having read access to the data the thing
is that if you just have multiplication
that's not very useful by itself for
example if you want to evaluate a
polynomial you need both multiplication
and addition and that is actually the
hard part for the cryptographers to
arrive at there's a lots of examples of
encryption schemes that give you either
addition or multiplication but an
encryption scheme that gives you both is
a relatively new thing
so the first homomorphic encryption
scheme that supports it both operations
and could be called fully homomorphic
was introduced
ten years ago and the encryption schemes
have come a long way since then so now
we have encryption schemes that support
both addition and multiplication of
encrypted integers the thing is that it
is still a bit slower than normal
computation but the great thing about it
is that it gives you a trust model that
really nothing else can
so with homomorphic encryption you keep
the secret key you don't give it to
anyone and you only have to trust the
math all right basically I want to do a
little bit of a detour and bring the
issue of privacy front and center
because good artificial intelligence
requires data and great deal of data is
stuff that we gather from what we do on
the internet or put in the cloud and
without certain safeguards like
homomorphic encryption generally things
are not private right yeah that's true
so there's an urgent need in my mind at
least for a new paradigm and and this is
what people are calling private AI what
is private AI and how can it help us so
private saya is actually a very broad
term and it is very broad because there
are lots of very different kinds of
privacy concerns so if we take for
example homomorphic encryption what
homomorphic encryption allows you to do
is you can make some parts of your data
encrypted so as a privacy concern it
addresses the concern of your data being
leaked as you hand it off to someone
else so if you encrypt sit with
homomorphic encryption is then and you
can do your a eye on the encrypted data
then you've kind of plugged that one
hole but now there's other kinds of
privacy concerns for example let's say
someone uses your data as a part of
their training set for training their
machine learning model now even if your
data doesn't get leaked it's gets
somehow integrated into like a parts of
the model that's getting trained because
that's what training means it has to
learn something about your data but you
wouldn't want someone to be able to
fully reconstruct your data just by
looking at that model and this is a form
of privacy that is addressed by
something called differential privacy
and as a technique this is completely
orthogonal to homomorphic encryption and
it addresses a concern that is very
orthogonal to what homomorphic
encryption can address right so I think
for private AI the goal should be to
first off look at what kind of privacy
problems there are in AI and provide
education to users because the
means that users don't even realize what
kinds of privacy problems there can be
and now if you've identified the
problems then obviously we should also
won't find the solutions for that fix it
but the education aspect is actually
very important for a private AI making
people realize what are the actual
implications of giving out their data or
using it in training ok well let's talk
about chat now not the guy who works in
men's suits at Nordstrom but the and I
quote optimizing compiler for fully
homomorphic neural network inferencing
again a mouthful I love it and
alternately you call it an optimizing
compiler for practical and interactive
private AI it's a tool stack for cloud
inference on private data give us a
virtual earth 3d view of chat and unpack
the stack for us yeah so this is
actually a project that got started with
this parasail research that I was
talking about previously so it actually
turns out that doing parallelization
helps with the homomorphic encryption
because homomorphic encryption behaves
better with parallel computations than
zero computations so this is how we got
into working with homomorphic encryption
in the first place then when we looked
at a homomorphic encryption as a target
for training as we were doing in
parasail we noticed that there's
actually a lot of other lower hanging
fruit that's we can do for homomorphic
encryption and instead of training we
started looking at inference so how do
you even like evaluate a neural network
model on top of homomorphic encryption
right which is a thing you need to be
able to do before you can actually do
training so what Chet is doing is it is
building a compiler for
homomorphic encryption that automates
many of these concerns that we would
otherwise have to deal with by hand
right for example it selects encryption
parameters automatically based on the
program you want to run and now it turns
out that neural network inferencing is
actually something that map's well on to
the capabilities of homomorphic
encryption so it's a very attractive
application to
okay so let's back up just a little bit
and say dis Chet to stand for something
a compiler for homomorphic encryption
yes so the T is coming from tensors so
it's a compiler for homomorphic
evaluation of tensor programs which is
kind of like a more programming language
flavored term for neural networks so
I've seen posters and Dex and
explanations and it's super technical
it sounds easy when you say automating
it there's a lot of work that goes into
getting it so that it's automated and
someone could use it that didn't have
the expertise you do so there is a lot
of work but I feel that the work is
actually in understanding the problem
actually in Chet's most of the
techniques are rather traditional
compiler techniques interesting I think
the magic comes in like finding the
right things to automate finding the
right abstraction to expose to the user
and then just implementing it but
there's a lot of kind of low-hanging
fruit in this space to be done all along
the tool stack and this is kind of what
we are addressing figuring out what the
problems are and then just taking in
rather standard techniques to address
them now I'm glossing over details
there's also much hard problems in this
space but so far the first things we've
addressed are kind of simple things that
no one had really looked at before and I
think a reason that this project has
been very fruitful is that it's a
collaboration between the right people
so we are collaborating with the
homomorphic encryption group who have
the knowledge of homomorphic encryption
and can explain the ideas to us and what
needs to be done and what is kind of
difficult to do and then if we need to
solve some problem they can explain the
mechanics of it and we are coming in as
programming languages compilers people
and we have the know-how on how to build
programming language tools tax on top of
computational targets and we can just
view homomorphic encryption as a
software CPU
it's an emulator for a CPU with a very
limited instruction set that just
happens to provide security if you use
it and we can just
target that's as any other compiler
would how do you feel when you are
working with other people with different
expertise and you start to get what
they're doing
I'm sensing like you said this project
informed this project and you know it
turns out that this helps that and I see
this flow of research and discovery but
it's pulling from different disciplines
and maybe applying a lens to a problem
that you didn't before and then it
expands your own horizons yes definitely
it has been a lot of learning so just as
in anecdotes when I came to Microsoft
research for my postdoc I had no
experience on machine learning or
homomorphic encryption previously I
started out with the project jet that
was doing machine learning on top of
homomorphic encryption so like it was
combining two applications areas both on
the compiler front and the back end that
I had no experience with but the key
part is that I had knowledge about
programming language techniques there in
the middle and that's allowed me to be
effective in this area so there was kind
of a relative advantage for me working
on this problem but it was also a lot of
learning and now do you feel like you
know just enough about those other areas
to be dangerous I would only be
dangerous at a cocktail party where I
could say homomorphic encryption and
some people would think I'm Way smarter
than I am
saying those words at the cocktail party
really kills the mood
all right well only we've reached the
part of the podcast where we discuss the
potential outcomes of your research both
intended and unintended and talked about
what could possibly go wrong
is there anything about your work that
quote-unquote keeps you up at night
anything that concerns you that we ought
to be thinking about or that we hope
you're thinking about yes
so most of my projects are rather safe I
cannot see how they would go horribly
wrong
but obviously the homomorphic encryption
parts could go like horribly wrong since
we are building a compiler for targeting
homomorphic encryption it places a lot
of responsibility on us to actually get
it right now homomorphic encryption is a
thing that is relatively easy to use in
a safe way meaning that most of the
mistakes you make will not actually leak
user data they'll make it return garbage
which is kind of a nice property but
there's a few things that we still need
to be careful with for example we need
to be careful to select correct
encryption parameters so that is
something we've put a lot of thoughts
into and there's also like it
defense-in-depth kind of perspective
here so Chet selects encryption
parameters and then seal which is
Microsoft's homomorphic encryption
library checks that those have been
selected correctly so there's kind of
two stages in that another thing that is
important in this space is open sourcing
so the seal encryption library is
actually currently open source it's
available on github and we are in the
process of open sourcing chats and
really in this kind of a space where
people are really concerned about their
privacy these kinds of projects really
need to be open source there's no other
way about it it really just buys trust
if someone is going to use it they
should be able to see what it does
well tell us a little bit about your
personal story or your journey from
Finland to Redmond what got a young Olli
Sarika v in Helsinki interested in
computer research and how did he end up
at Microsoft Research so I actually
started out studying physics so I did a
year of that and noticed that it was not
for me I think the main reason was that
I wasn't actually very interested in the
day-to-day of doing physics but I was
interested in the day-to-day of doing
computer science which is programming
and I enjoyed the process of it so and
that's what really the early driving
factor into going deeper into computer
science then I worked with a professor
ko Helen ko who had an extensive
background on model checking and that's
how I got into this testing and software
verification stuff and in the field of
testing and verification Microsoft
researches and the best in the world it
has like a significant selection of the
best people in the world specifically in
the rice group in this field so you
couldn't not be aware of Microsoft
Research when working in this area and I
think like the biggest thing that struck
me about the papers I was reading coming
out of Microsoft Research was the access
to important problems so inside
Microsoft there's obviously lots of
software getting written so the field of
program analysis just has a lot of
material to work on and that is so
important so working as a company like
Microsoft is really an advantage so
that's why I wanted to get into
Microsoft research and now having gotten
into it so it's it's amazing like you
work with such great people I love it so
what was your educational background
where did you go to school and how did
you you know wander across the pond as
it were so that's actually an
interesting question
I started out school in India which I
hadn't mentioned before and this school
in India was an American school the
American embassy school which is a very
interesting school it's basically like a
piece
of America just transplanted into the
middle of New Delhi and on the first day
going to school there I did not know a
word of English so I was just kind of
thrown into the deep end basically but
that gave me a great background in
English and I think that has actually
helped me a lot as a researcher because
you have to communicate so much research
is like all about communication so
having a strong grasp of the language
has helped me so I'm intrigued now how
did you go from Finland to India to an
American school was there some family
connection or yeah so it was actually my
father who was a engineer / manager at
Nokia and he got sent on an assignment
to India to set up the business there so
that was only 2 years so much although
then I came back to back to Finland and
went to university there yeah yeah so
all of my university schooling has been
in Finland including your PhD yes
and then the internships were what
brought you here yeah so I managed to
get an internship during my PhD studies
and apparently it went well so I managed
to get another and then they finally
hired me on as a postdoc so yeah well
actually the question I was gonna ask
you about what one interesting trait has
helped you in your career as a
researcher that little tidbit about an
American school in India from a Finnish
guy it's pretty much the funniest thing
I've heard but is there anything else
that you have like some tidbit that we
couldn't find about you on a web search
that has actually influenced your career
as a researcher yeah I actually went to
boarding school for my high school but
it was a strange kind of boarding school
it was a stem focused boarding school in
the middle of the Finnish countryside
like no civilization for kilometres
around it takes in 20 students a year
and everyone's a nerd basically and that
was the first place where I realized
that there's lots of people who are a
lot smarter than me so I was like
mediocre in that school which I think
was an important formative experience as
a researcher it teaches like
intellectual
community which i think is a good trait
to have yes it is for 20 kids 20 kids a
year yeah and how are you selected there
was a selection process yeah you had to
take a test basically like high school
level math I think they also select
people a lot due to personality and like
they need to find 20 kids that can
actually live in a boarding school going
home only every second weekend and it's
a personal character and you know got a
long ability people who fit in a group
so would you say prior to that that you
thought you were the smartest kid on the
planet yeah so in in the grades before
that there was like maybe one kid who
kind of rivaled me so I think that's a
typical experience for many people going
into research early on and I think it's
important to get fast into the stage
where you're not the smartest person in
the room as we close I want to give you
the last word so here's your chance to
say anything you want by way of advice
or inspiration or maybe wisdom or
warning to our listeners many of whom
are in somewhere close to where you are
on your career path maybe a little bit
behind what would you say to emerging
researchers who might be interested in
following your footsteps well as you've
heard now I've touched many topics in my
research but I think one thing that has
helped me in each of these topics is
working on a project that someone
actually cares about that there is some
user that you can picture in your mind
that you can sympathize with and you can
like think of what their problems are it
changes the research question from what
tricky problem could I solve into more
of like what tricky problem do I need to
solve for this specific application that
I'm looking at and it just makes going
deep into the research problem so much
easier because you can just imagine your
problem and look at what the problems to
solve are and it also makes writing
papers easier your motivation section
comes for free when you have actual
motivation so I would really encourage
people to do the work of defining their
problem
and finding a problem that is actually
well motivated and for sure it is work
to do that you could just take the first
hard problem that comes along but not
all hard problems are actually useful
problems to solve only sorry kV thank
you so much for coming in thank you very
much
[Music]
to learn more about dr. only sake be and
how researchers are inviting efficiency
to the privacy party visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]